Hank: Trying to go behind the sides to shoot our video
John: By the way, stop trying to make "behind the sides" happen.
John: Hank, this is a set for a play. We have somehow found our selves -
Hank: Oh, well yeah it is!
John: - In a small theater
Hank: It seems like a really good place to make a video!
I don't know my line.
John: Oh!
Hank: Hm, that's something.
Hank: I definitely don't know what I'm doing
Hank: I don't know how any of this works
Heard voices I heard a lot of voices behind that door it was locked. I'm gonna run away.
Good morning, John. It's Tuesday.
We look great. Okay? This is happening. Hank before we start the video in earnest
I just want to get rid of the elephant in the room and acknowledge that yes. I have shaved my mustache
I'm so nervous that people are gonna walk in that door if they do its fine. Almost never in my life
have I not been nervous when Hank was nervous. This is a very new feeling for me. Pineapple or no, I'm sorry Hank,
what was the late squid it's question Tuesday the day we answer real questions from real nerdfighters?
Pineapple or no?! Yeah pineapples exist. Or.. or like it that the option you either have pineapple use of the word "no" mmm
I'd take a pineapple. I might take "no", I find "no" to be a very useful word
What's your pizza eating method, John? I take it off and I roll it up
And then I slice it so that it's like a like a cinnamon roll of Pizza- Hank is so nervous right now
I just want to get the video over with so we can get out of here before we get caught!
There is no getting caught we are where we are supposed to be. I had to take my shoe off the block a door!
opinions on next day Pizza? Oh
Strongly Pro. Reheated or cold? just pulled out of the fridge and eaten. Oh, it's in the fridge. Oh god
Yes
Hank will eat
Anything! like we go to gas stations on tour and Hank's like "can I have this corn dog?
That's been slowly rotating for 14 hours!" They don't rotate the corn dog
They just keep them under the heat tray. Only the hot dogs get rolled around. Ugh how-.. I mean
That's the kind of thing you shouldn't know because you shouldn't eat that stuff in gas stations. Why is it there then? John
What would you do inside a whale?
Oh.. um.. Panic. How did I get there? Did I get swallowed?
Yeah, like what part of the whale am I in? Right if I'm like next to the butt can I get out the butt?
Whale hearts are big enough that you could probably be in the whale aorta. Yeah a blue whale, and then it's a bad day for the whale.
Right the whale's having a heart attack. Cause I can't swim that fast!
And I'd just get caught
downstream like in one of the junctions, right in the nuts. Do whales have nuts? No, in my nuts. A blood vessel split and my legs
Go on either side. Oh. Yeah, do the splits. And also yes, whales have nuts. Great,
good to know. They're on the inside though. And people say you don't learn anything from
Vlogbrothers' videos. Would you rather have a pizza-sized John or a John-sized pizza?
It's an interesting question what you would do in real life
If suddenly a miniature version of yourself showed up. You wouldn't do with anything with it, you would have to let it decide what to do
for itself. Right you have you have to be like "Go...go free little me...And if you love me you'll come back."
have you ever eaten real pizza in Italy I have. Yeah. It had too many olives on it
It was basically an olive. I find Italian pizza to be a little bit overrated to be honest with you. America:
"We don't make stuff we make stuff better." That's a great line
It's not always true. But it doesn't really matter whether it's true, it matters whether it sounds good
Welcome to 2017. Is it true that whale nuts are on the inside. Yes that is true
How do you know that? Have you ever seen a whale? I looked it up
I know the honest with the answer is that I looked it up. I looked it up one day. I was like "where are whale nuts?"
And I found out where they were. What play do you think this is for Hank? uhhhh
like "Arsenic and Old Lace" "Death of a Salesman"
Yeah, it could be that. At any rate Hank. I I'm glad that we got to perform , unexpectedly, on this stage.
You know what it seems like to me is the kind of formal living room where like anytime you sat down in it as a
Kid you knew you were in trouble. Or that your hamster died.
Right! "We had something serious to talk to you about. Your terrible dog ate your beloved hamster"
We do have to go on the stage now. Not this stage (peasants) the real one. Yeah. Yeah, we yep. Goodbye John
I'll see you now
There I am. Oh God!